today classic car expert Christophe
Bauer is taking a pioneer of safety and
engine technology out for a spin the
mercedes-benz 220 se be popularly known
as the fini the official name of this
series introduced in 1959 is the w111
the most innovative model in the series
shines with its elaborate fuel injection
system
these MIT thes the Mercedes 220 se be
wrote automotive history says Christophe
Vinnie was the first sedan in the world
made in large numbers to feature a
four-stroke engine with fuel injection
but Sadie's had already been using this
highly innovative and extremely
efficient technology since the end of
the 1950s but only in very expensive
small edition models
she has a Linux order in 1954 the
legendary supercar the mercedes-benz
300sl became the first serial production
model to feature a four-stroke engine
with direct injection that made more
power and cleaner exhaust from less fuel
[Music]
statesmen began profiting from the new
technology in 1957 the last versions of
the 300d known as the are Dena had
intake manifold injection but these
luxury vehicles like the fuel injection
Ponton 220 se built for just two years
were available only in small numbers
[Music]
right the gasoline injection system went
under the food of the top model of w111
series in 1959 sis crystal to show what
this new development could do Mercedes
sent the seemingly staid premium sedan
on to the toughest racetracks and rally
routes in the world in 1960 racecar
driver
Valtor shock won the prestigious Monte
Carlo Rally and the European Touring Car
Championship with a 220 ACP
the sedan one the Touring Car Grand Prix
of Argentina in 1961 and with a woman at
the wheel also in 1962 a V horse West of
Sweden left all the men in the dust
and in 1963 a triumphed at the six hour
race on the Nurburgring
[Music]
for Langston the long-distance race is
handling and quality and balance of the
engine are crucial and the fini has
smooth extremely precise power steering
suspension is comfortable yet quite
sporty Mercedes calls this active safety
[Music]
the interior is built for safety - says
Christoph for example with the padded
steering wheel and impact plate padded
dashboard recessed knobs and switches
some of them made of flexible plastic
Christopher's particularly admires the
wedge pin lock which keeps the doors
from popping open in an accident our
expert says mercedes engineer belaboring
he invented the principle of impassive
safety with this car visually the car
was oriented towards the extremely
popular American design big panorama
windshield and tail fins vote
understated ones in comparison with us
cars with Mercedes tailfins weren't
designed for designs sake oh no says
Christoph Sade's called them - piyo
stager or sight lines and said they
helped you parallel park
Jeanne's technology with the fini
Mercedes head designer Carla Villefort
created a car body with clean lines and
timeless elegance that was used in three
model series
[Music]
the vertical bar displays speedometer
was standard starting in 1962 the 220 SC
be offered an optional automatic
transmission that harmonized beautifully
with the 120 horsepower engine
[Music]
he under that water standard under the
w111 hood was a 2.2 litre straight-six
engine and only in this model the SE B
is there a well designed mechanical fuel
injection system that ensures that each
of the six cylinders receives just the
right amount of finely atomized gasoline
air mixture when it needs it that's much
more effective than a normally
carbureted engine in which the same
amount of fuel is aspirated with every
stroke of the piston whether you're just
flooring it or just using a lot and to
him delighted of course this engine can
no longer be considered a fuel saver by
today's standards
[Music]
if driven aggressively the 120
horsepower short stroke engine will burn
14 litres or more per 100 kilometers but
it can do a hundred and seventy two
kilometres an hour and has a powerful
sonorous sound the 220 se be sets high
standards
technically the sedan was among the best
of its time it was continually improved
and remained in production for six years
[Music]
the matific from the Mercedes Phinney
really set standards crystal says
crumple zone and reinforced passenger
compartment its safety concept has
become a fundamental feature of car
construction almost 300,000 w111 s were
sold 66 thousand of them as 220 snv's
with trailblazing fuel injection
that's the technological standards today
you rarely find a car that combines so
many innovations so the Mercedes - 20 s
CB is truly a milestone of automotive
history and our top university thanks to
the fini mercedes-benz built the safest
cars of the early 1960s and built up a
reputation the brand still profits from
today
you